الرياض تخطف انظار العالم بجوائز جوي اوز
و نصر الله يتسول الاموال من دول الخليج
والدموع في وداع رئيسه وزراء نيوزيلندا
اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
برعايه هيئه الترفيه ممثله برئيسها تركي
ال الشيخ واللي مجموعه كبيره من النجوم
الوطن العربي
بجمعتهم في الرياض عنوانهم العريض لهذه
الليله
[موسيقى]
طبعا مثل ما قلت لكم حفل جوائز صناعه
الثالثه من خلاله تكريم عدد كبير من
النجوم والفنانين والمؤثرين بجوائز في
مجالات التلفزيون والسينما والرياضه
والموسيقى بالاضافه لبعض الوجوه الجديده
في تلك الفئات دعما للمواهب الشابه لهم
وتميز الحفل هذه السنه بتقديم جوائز فخريه
وفي منها تم تقديمه لاول مره وكرم خلال
رئيس هيئه الترفيه تركي ال الشيخ عدد من
النجوم العرب والاجانب فحصل الشيخ وليد ال
ابراهيم رئيس مجلس اداره ام بي سي على
الجائزه الماسيه
احمد حلمي ومنى زكي محمد منير حياه الفهد
سعد عبد الله نوال وسالم الهندي الرئيس
التنفيذي لشركه روتانا كلهم
هذه جائزه مميزه نقدمها لاول مره
جاي الماسيه لان لشخصيه ماسيه من بلد
الحبيب تفضل شيخ وليد
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اميتاب باتشان
[موسيقى]
الجائزه اللي تفتخر فيهم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وغير الاجواء الجميله اللي ميزت الحفل ففي
مشهد كان لافت في الحفل كمان هو حضور
اللاعب اشرف حكيمي اللي خطف الاضواء
كالعاده مع والدته وفاز بجائزه افضل رياضي
عربي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اشرف حكيم
اني تعالي تعالي تعالي معه
[موسيقى]
وكمان من بين الحضور لفتت الانظار جورجينا
رودريغيز صديقه النجم البرتغالي كريستيانو
رونالدو اللي شاركت في اول فعاليه لها
وقدمت جائزه افضل لاعب رياضيه وكانت شاركت
صوره كمان لاطلالتها من الحفل وشكرت كل
الناس على محبتها وعبرت كمان عن محبتها
للسعوديه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اريد فيميل اصلي
السعوديه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
هل لبنان اهم اوروبا من مصر
هل لبنان اهم للسعوديه من مصر
هل لبنان اهم
للخليج من مصر
الخليج
النتيجه
300 مليار
يحسبوا حالهم يلعبوا فوتبول
في دوله عربيه على حافه الانهيار في دوله
عربيه
لاعبين كبار ومهمين ومحترمين ودوليين
بسمعنا لا رونالدو ميسي
قبل ما اتكلم ولا علق في فيديو ثاني حابه
اذكركم فيه بس بالله هذه المره ركزوا
واسمعوا كويس
السطح
موازنه حزب الله
ومعاشاته ومصاريفه واكله وشربه وسليحه
وصواريخه من الجمهوريه الاسلاميه في ايران
طالما بايران في فلوس
يعني نحنا في عندنا فلوس
ومالنا المقوى لنا يصل الينا
يا سلام يا سلام طيب ايوه بالضبط هذا هو
نفس الشخص لكن في زمنين مختلفين كان في
الاول شايف نفسه وبيتفاخر بدعم ايران له
يا ارض اشتدي ما عليك جدي واليوم بدون خجل
وبكل جراه بيتسول الدعم المالي من دول
الخليج وخصوصي من السعوديه ولا لا وبيقول
البلد على حافه الانهيار طيب مو من عمايلك
هو على حافه الانهيار هو كده انهار لوحده
يعني البلد نهارت من وراء تمويل وتدريب
العصابات الارهابيه والمعسكرات وغيره
بالنشاطات حزب الله وعلى فكره في نقطه
مهمه ابغى اقول لها يعني في الفيديو
القديم اللي شايف نفسه في الدعم الدعم
الايراني بيقول مدام في في فلوس في ايران
فا نحن امورنا بخير طيب تفضل روح ليش ما
بتطلب منهم يعني خلاص خلصت فلوسي ايران
وقلت خلينا نغير المسار ونطلب الدعم من
دول الخليج
الخلاصه يا جماعه بيلخصها يعني صراحه
المثل اللي بيقول ان لم تستحي فافعل ما
شئت لكن عشان نفهم اكثر يعني راح نحاول
نفهم قرائب نصر الله بس انه يعني خلينا
نحاول على الاقل يعني معنا من واشنطن
الناشط السياسي اللبناني جنوا رعيدي اهلا
فيك معنا همم يعني تحول صراحه همم
مضحك مثير للسخريه يعني عجيب ما نستخدم
كمان كده الفاظ اكثر من كده يستحقها هذا
التحول بس ايش برايك سببه
برايي هذا الشيء اللي عم يعملوا حزب الله
صار له فتره يعني حزب الله يشغلته سياسه
الامتزاز يمكن باللاجئين شو عم يصير
بلبنان ومثل ما تفضلت وقلت انه من وراء
صار لانهيار بس وقت يمكن حاسس انه النظام
بايران بطل كثير ماشي حاله قال انه بركي
لازم نقله بنجرب ناخذ مصاري من الخليل من
السعوديه بس الناس هو اخر كم سنه يعني جرب
بيعمل ان امتي كانه العدو الاول ولا لبنان
تحت امره حزب الله هو دول الخليج اللي هو
منه شيء بس وتنزل شويه نظام شفنا هذا وهي
مش اول مره بيعمل هيك نصر الله متذكر اول
الثوره اللبنانيه 2019 طلع هو عن الاشخاص
يلي من وراه بص اللبنان
فاذا بتتذكر وقت قال انه احنا ما راح نجوع
وراح نضل الدولار
كثير الرنانه متنقش شرقا ونطشه ما باعرف
وين بعد يعني ولا مره بنشوف اكشن بينعمل
هذا الافكار تبعون الرنانه وصلولهن حكمين
لبنان ويلي ما يلي ما بيحكي مثل ما هن
بدهم ينقتل يعني لقمان سنين مش من زمان
همم
[موسيقى]
الكبتاجون كل يومين ثلاثه
كل هدف طبعا
ده دول هلا زعلان بده منه المصاري ثم
اعمل يعني وقف على الهدوء الانظمه منه
[موسيقى]
يبقى كده انكتبوا انقطع الصوت عنه انقطع
الارسال
للسخريه
بهذا الحد اللي كان
بس يعني السؤال هو انه الان لما بيعمل طلب
من هذا النوع يعني وبيقول هذا الكلام هل
هو متوقع انه يعني دول الخليج هتجيء
تساعده يعني مثلا الان بعد هذا كله
استهلاك طبعا
سوء اليوم همم
النظام الاقتصادي بلبنان راح الناس همم
دولار 50,000 غيره يعني من ثلاث سنين كده
دائما بيفتش على اشخاص كرمال لحد عليهم
الصوديوم هو يذكر انه هو مثل السعوديه عم
تدفع 300 مليار لحد ستار مثل رونالدو طيب
وبعدين
عندي لك سؤال يعني يا جينو صراحه مين مفيد
اكتر رونالدو ولا حسن نصر الله
وكم مد دعايه للي صارت من رونالدو و و و و
كثير من الاشياء والتفاصيل يعني الموضوع
كانت يعني جميله ومفيده وجميله حتى للدوري
السعودي نصر الله ايش هنستفيد نحن منه
300 مليار دولار ما بيفتكر بس الاستهلاش
شفته لو بس الخليجيه بساعدونا احنا ماشي
حالنا فيتغدوا النظر انه تحت حزب الله
وتحت حكم حزب الله وصلنا لهون وميشال عون
ونبيه بري
تريلات
صار كل الافكار تبعون انه اعطونا مصاري
للناس اللي هو اتاكيندام
السعوديه كالعاده على فشله همم
على العموم غرائب نصر الله لا تنتهي طبعا
شكرا لك على هذه المداخله كان معنا من
واشنطن السياسي اللبناني الجنوب عادي شكرا
لك
مازال اسم رئيسه وزراء نيوزيلندا ايضا الي
اعلنت بشكل مفاجئ انه ما عاد عندها طاقه
لترشح من جديد وتكمل اربع سنوات كمان
هنا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ميسي ميسي
[تصفيق]
وطبعا من وقت ما اعلنت جسمنا عن استقالتها
والتحليلات عن سبب الاستقاله المفاجاه مات
وقفت طبعا واللي من بينها تفسيرات وحده
بتقول انا ما عندي طاقه خلاص يعني اكيد
بتعاني من الاحتراق الوظيفي وهو حاله من
الارهاق والتعب الجسدي والعاطفي اللي يمكن
ان يحدث بعد التعرض لضغط طويل الامد في
الوظيفه وتم الاعتراف باعتبار حاله طبيه
في عام 2019 من قبل منظمه الصحه العالميه
خلينا نعرف اكثر عن همم هذه الحاله وهذا
الموقف يعني اللي صدم كثيرين وتنضم الينا
من القاهره الدكتوره حنان عبد المنعم
خبيره التنميه البشريه اهلا فيك معنا
الدكتوره همم حنان همم يعني يمكن موضوع
الاحتراق الوظيفي هذا صار لنا فتره بنتكلم
فيه بس الان رجع للوجه لما ننصدمنا انه
رئيسه وزراء تطلع وتقول انا ما عاد عندي
طاقه اكثر من كده يعني حسيت انصدمت انت
برده من هذا الموضوع ولا حسيت انه برده
حتى هي مسكينه زي انا موظفه في نهايه
اليوم
مساء الخير عليكم الاول من القاهره اول
درس انت الحقيقه يعني هي كيف استديو
الحقيقه يعني من ساعه ما طلعت وابتدينا
نسمع على انها 37 سنه اصغر رئيس وزراء
لبلد زي نيوزيلندا حاجه طبعا
حقيقي حاجه تشرف جدا على انها امراه او
على انها 37 سنه وبعدين فاجاتنا بعد كده
بالسنه اللي فاتت برده في فرحها في يناير
قالت عشان قبه نايتين انا لغيت الفرح
فطبعا دي واحده فاهمه بتعمل ايه وعندها
فيجن وميشن لحياتها قبل اي حاجه ثانيه
بعد كده
الدكتور
حكمها كان فتره حكمها كان فيها صعبه كان
في التفجير الكبير الارهابي اللي واجهته
نيوزيلندا كان في كورونا كان في هذه
الاشياء كلها
ده حقيقي
اه لانها هي قالت حاجه مهمه جدا قالت
حاجتين لازم يدرسوا بالصبر قالت انا بشر
فرحان وقت الرحيل انا بشر سحانه وقت
الرحيل يعني حاسه انها مش مفروض ان هي هي
حاسه هي ايه وبتدور على كواليتي اوف لايف
بتدور على ان هي الحقيقه مهما
المناصب والكرسي لا انا انا عايزه سلام
نفسي ده نمبر وان نمبر تو الحاجه برده
اللي خليتني فعلا اتوقف عندها انها لما
قالت ان طاقتها استنفذه وانها مش قادره اا
تحقق العداله
اخشى ان نكون طاقتها خلاص كده كفايه انها
ما تحققش العداله الحقيقه اثنين يعني
موقفين ونقطتين مهمين جدا الاولانيه بتقول
لك ان انا بني ادمه زي اي حد في الدنيا
وده طبعا الحقيقه في وطننا العربي لا ده
حاجه مختلفه تماما عن اللي بيحصل ان هي
عندها شجاعه غير عاديه اهي عايزه تكسب
نفسها بس على فكره
كمان دكتوره حنان يعني في ناس قالوا انه
لو كان رجل ما كان تخلى عن مهام الوظيفيه
الحقيقه لا الحقيقه هي دورت عارفه ان هي
المناصب بتحرق البني ادمين والبناصر بتبقى
ليها مسؤوليات شديده جدا وهي فقاره زي اي
حد في الدنيا
اقدر ابص على حاجه ثانيه فقط
عن عبد المنعم خبيره التنميه البشريه شكرا
لك
هو الرسمي اول بيترقبوا العالم وعشاق نادي
النصر السعودي للنجم البرتغالي كريستيانو
رونالدو بقميص النصر في اول مباراه له في
دوري روشن السعودي لكره القدم راح يواجه
النصر ضيفه نادي الاتفاق على ارضيه ملعب
مرسول مبارك ضمن مباريات الجوله ال 14
للدوري السعودي هذه المباراه اللي راح
تعلن بدايه مغامره رياضيه جديده لرونالدو
لكل العالم جالس به يترقبها وكان نادي
النصر كمان حماس متابعين ومشجعينه
المباراه الجديده
[تصفيق]
مشاهدينا احنا وصلنا لختام حلقه اليوم
تابعونا دائما نتابع فيديوهات الحلقه على
صفحاتنا على مواقع التواصل وطبعا كمان
تقدر توجهوا كاميرات هواتفكم لي الكيو ار
كود اللي ظاهر اسفل الشاشه وانا ان شاء
الله ارجع بكره والقاكم بحلقه جديده من
تفاعلكم والمزيد من المواضيع الشيقه
وحلقاتنا دايما حلوه
[موسيقى]